Thank you so much.
Thank you David.
And for those of you don't know,
David,
David is really one of the
pioneers of executive coaching,
really one of the people who I think have
written so thoughtfully and inspiring
ways about where we can
find a life that matters.
And that's what's so terrific to have
an opportunity to talk with all of you
about today. Here at Google. I feel like
I've been in a Google office every week.
I was just in Singapore and London and
New York and I'm on my way to Joburg when
this is the front desk at Burg,
uh, Google. It's how's it jumbo?
And so I feel so welcome when I come
here and I love coming to Google because
it's a particularly point in time for
me because I started on a passion play
about 20 years ago where
I was in a late night.
Nightcap will admit it was
one o'clock in the morning.
We were in Switzerland and we
were jet lagged and exhausted.
And I was talking to a couple of famous
Googlers. It was Larry and Sergey.
They were at the World Economic Forum
and we were all just gushing about having
met someone iconic in our lives
that we never thought we would need.
It was one of his last public appearances.
It was Nelson Mandela,
and we're thinking about how this guy
should have been the most angry man in
Africa and yeah.
What did he do with his life?
He decided to reinvent a life
that mattered for millions
in rethinking the way
that he could have impact and a
sense of belonging for a culture,
and that set me on a path that
would be life changing for me.
I had been building businesses most
of my career as an entrepreneur and I
decided that I wanted to pursue this
question of how to create a life that
matter.
Could we find the DNA?
Could we find some ingredients by
interviewing enough successful,
high achieving people around the planet
and could we unlock some of those
secrets?
Please come and sit down.
I'm loving the opportunity also to be on
live streaming and for those of you who
did get books and didn't get books,
I'll make sure that you get free copies.
So just ping me through the Google
network and for those that I might see in
other cities,
please let me know if you're interested.
I'd love to share with you
a little research that we
learned about how to create
a life that matters and so here's
where I want to go. With that,
I want to start with just a little piece
of archival footage here of just the
first 60 seconds of the first interview
we did starting in 1998 and I'm going to
bring you to present and then share with
you eight of the principals out of the
36 that we learned and the eight that
I've picked is big because they are the
most, I think, hidden from
our souls and from the public.
They are the ones that
aren't talked about,
the ones that have the biggest impact.
And let me share with you, herb Kelleher,
kind of a famously happy guy who
seems to create a life that matters,
even though he's really just
running a discount airline.
Oh,
so what job are we going to get it?
And you can't really screw up.
Hey,
how are you?
So it was amazing to be able
to meet people like herb,
who in a sadly on unusual way,
when you meet CEOs aren't
necessarily the most happy people.
And when you talked to him,
you could see how that filters
through the organization.
How many of you've ever been on
southwest airlines? Of course. Yeah,
we've all had to do that.
You,
I was kinda coming here on southwest
airlines and I had the typical safety talk
that you get on southwest. Now these
people can't be paid all that much.
Not In money at least. But why is it
that they're just a little happier?
A little bit more engaged, maybe a
little insane. Have you noticed this?
We were like rolling out on the runway
and the flight attendant was giving us
the safety talk. You know, nobody's
listening. We're all reading our devices.
Can you starts to pretend
to be angry. He says, guys,
if this plane falls out of the sky,
would you like to know the documentation?
You can hear the thud. You know,
people are dropping everything.
What's this guy up to us? It's
okay. Here's what's going to happen.
If there's a change in cabin pressure
or there's a crisis in the year and
they're going to be the little yellow
masks that pop out of the ceiling.
Now folks, those are oxygen
masks. Now don't start to ask,
why is my mask smaller than his mask?
Why is my mask inconveniencing the
meeting that I'm supposed to hold? No,
grab of the mask, put it on yourself
first and then put it on your child.
And if you have more than one child,
you might want to stop and consider
which one really has the most potential.
And that's what I want to talk about here
because this is how when you talked to
her, when we did that
interview, he was, he drank a,
I think a full scotch. Uh, the, the bottle
was empty by the time we were talking.
Two hours didn't seem
to affect him in bed.
He went through two packs of cigarettes,
was blowing this, the it off screen.
He said,
you know,
mark and people will not decide and choose
explicitly and intentionally to live
a life that matters. We have to take
a moment and recalibrate. You know,
we're not Nelson Mandela.
There's probably many times during your
life when you redefine what success
means and what that
definition of success is.
So let's look at the factors that
we discovered in this research.
And one of them had to do with the fact
that in a world that's so volatile and
changing, we're all on this mission
to find a sense of belonging,
to create a life that matters.
And the,
the primary principle that seemed to
flow through all of these came out of a
research project as I mentioned.
And the project started with bill to last.
I don't know if you've ever
heard of bill to last. You know,
it was one of those great books,
one of the many books that was a
bestseller and half of it was true.
And I had the opportunity to be a part
of the research team at Stanford that was
working on this,
but part of that slave labor that was
doing all of the conjoint analysis and
Jerry when it Wharton joined us,
Howard Moskowitz at Harvard,
Benita Thompson led the research.
She's a behavioral psychologist.
We work with Jim Collins and we then
went on a survey of people who we thought
had an impact for 20 years or more.
In other words,
the cohort that we went after were not
people who are one hit wonders or short
term success stories.
We're talking about people who had
impact for at least two decades.
These were people who had been living
a life that matters and they might be
celebrities, they might
not be. Many of them were.
I did have a very eclectic experience.
It started with Nelson Mandela had
the opportunity to meet Maya Angelou.
I did many programs with her.
The Dalai Lama met the famous Googlers
and the folks at Microsoft from the very
early days.
That just shows how you know this is going
back to 1998 when when Larry bought a
youtube and was talking about that at the,
at the forum and into the present day
and the adventure ended up finding these
criteria,
36 criteria in 2000 interviews that
we did and then we did a survey in 110
nations to try to force rank what were
these criteria on the definition of
success and what we found was that one
of the great core competencies of people
like yourself who have achieved is that
you start to work at putting your demons
in a place where you can perhaps
harvest the energy from them.
That it's a bit about mastering fear
and ambition and let me share with you a
little bit what I mean about that.
What we found was that people who have
been able to find a connection with a
life that matters tend
to be great at failure.
Winners lose often and they lose more
often than losers because losers are
usually trying to avoid the risk
of making mistakes that winners,
people who have impact year in and year
at are usually experts at learning,
at iteration, at being able to
profit from failure and from change.
And I don't know about you guys,
I've kind of often feel
this way in all of my work.
I always have way too much more to
do than I possibly can and short it.
Short cuts kind of never
apply when we do this.
So here's the first principle at work.
We found that anyone who had really swung
for the fences in high achievement had
also failed big time and they were experts
at trying to harvest their failures.
Let me give you just one exercise that
we can all apply in how we would rethink
any sort of disaster that we've
ever been in. So Richard Branson,
who was one of the early
sponsors of this book,
had a tragedy occur where he had been
collecting 30 years of his notes in the
family home on Necker island.
And it burned down four
years ago. Quite famously,
a bolt of lightning came through the roof.
He had been sleeping on the beach and
the house was filled with people and his
90 year old bum eve was able to escort
actually everybody out of the house when
this big explosion occurred and she's
still bragging about it to this day,
eve is, and he said, I learned
something really profound that day.
Obviously I was really worried
about people being hurt,
but then I realized how helpless I was in
that disaster. I was down on the beach,
he was starting to run to do the rescue
and he realized he wasn't fully clothed,
he was barefoot.
He ran straight into a cactus.
It wasn't a pleasant experience for him
and he realized something that informed
30 years of his work that had gone up in
smoke and that is that if you did want
to restart a life or a
career or a business,
do you think you would do that in
exactly the same blueprint that you had
leading up to that point of disaster?
In other words,
one of the greatest ways to think about
looking forward in your life is to
restart the old life.
In other words,
would you have the same blueprint
for that House that you rebuild?
Would you have that same work plan
for your career or would you do things
differently?
Would you think about every aspect or
process of your work or career in the same
way?
I don't think so that one of the best
ways we can think about our goal setting
every year as it is to say, what if I
were to start over? What would I do here?
Friendly?
How can I avoid just paving
the cow path as they say?
Would it be the same team?
Whereas really truly the value
creation in our life and work.
Think about that.
Restart when you're doing your goal
setting rather than just thinking about
incrementing yourself into the
next thing you work on. Now,
I'm going to give you some
more tools to unpack this,
but I wanted to start there because
a lot of the work that we do,
and it's a lot of the effort that we put
into the work that we do ends up being
through inertia,
and I hate this quote with Edison
talking about failure. You know,
10,000 ways that it didn't work,
but the truth of the matter is that when,
when we make effort and we are feeling
like we're having a setback or re
humiliated from that effort,
the the truth of the matter is that the
people who are continuing to have impact
continue to do that and learn from that
experience rather than allow themselves
to be weighed under the pressures of it,
that that whenever he gets criticized,
he thinks about the experience
he has like this virgin,
we have more experience in our,
Our name would suggest
that it's about iteration.
It's about the capacity to be
able to fail and move on this.
That's the second principle that we
learned from this group of high achievers
like yourself was that is
there anyone in this room has,
who's ever wanted to do
something important in their
life or work where others
didn't approve of them?
Of course,
we've all had or continue to have
constantly what we call the silent scream.
What is it in your life or work that
others who love you, want to protect,
you are trying to suppress or would hope
that you'd make something of yourself
so that you take another
path in your life and work.
This ends up being a very
common pattern for all of us,
and usually we tolerate it.
In fact,
we ended up fueling it because we do
the second piece of the silent scream.
The first piece ends up being,
we're allowing others to perhaps deny
that part of our life that we care about.
And then secondly, we will
often hide that passion. Well,
that's kind of our secret.
It's what we don't want other people
to trash because it's something that we
love and something that we treasure.
And then the irony of all
this is that quite frankly,
people who love you can see right through
the ceiling like silent scream, right?
The truth of the matter is it oozes out
around all the edges that when we do
coaching with high
achievers like yourself,
we find all the time that there's that
silent scream that's worth being aware of.
It's worth trying to build a plan
of safety around that silent scream.
We're going to talk more about how to
develop a safe way to pursue your silent
scream, but here's a glimpse at how
we found this cohort around the world.
In 110 nations started to deal with this.
We didn't find any person who is
doing something extraordinarily well,
who didn't have a portfolio passions.
There isn't just one thing to do with
our lives that usually there was a main
expertise that was driven by an obsession,
but there was always a
portfolio of passions,
other parts of that silent scream
that you tap that feeds you,
that restore you, that allow
you to recover, that allow
you to become resilient,
that allow you to in a sense create a
more rich and full life that matters.
There's an obsession,
I think now with expertise and being very
precise about just what one area that
we focus on and what we found is that
people who've had endearing lives of
creativity and contribution have a silent
scream that contributes to a portfolio
of passions and it's about,
it's about putting a spotlight on
what those are for you and your life.
The third area that I found a bit
ironic is that that people who are high
achieving have a paradoxical
pumpkin combination of both
Hubris and humility and
other was Hubris. You have to have
people like my friend Gail Devers,
she went to four Olympics.
Now,
this woman on the fourth Olympic got a
gold medal and she lamented the fact that
she hadn't broken the world
record said seriously gale,
I mean four Olympics. And what we
found was that on the one hand,
she has this enormous Hubris to believe
that she can do so well at something and
the humility to realize that I always
want to get better and that nothing that I
achieved can't be done without.
And through the efforts of others,
that it's a combination of Hubris and
humility that drives people to have high
impact.
Uh,
we talked to Sally fields early on
in the interviews that we were doing.
She's one of the few women who've worked
for 40 years on stage and screen Emmy
and an academy award winning actress
started out in meaningless roles,
ended up doing very meaningful
high contribution work.
Listen to how she describes her journey.
The only thing that you have power
over is to get good at what you do.
That's all there is. That's all there is.
There ain't no more. And the only time,
the only way you become a
leader or any such, you know,
highfalutin terminology, a role
model and leader, uh, you know,
give back is to have something to
give back. You see, the only reason,
the only way you have something to
give back, it's go do something,
get off your rear end and go do something.
And that doesn't mean I'm going to go,
you know,
build a housing for the underprivileged.
That's good too. But go
become a doctor, a lawyer,
an Indian chief goal and worked your tail
off and achieve something for yourself.
Some specific thing,
but be excellent at what that is.
That's the only way that you can be a
leader who wakes up one day and says,
hmm, should I go to school or
shall I be a leader? Let's see,
what shall I do today?
I think I'm going to go out and lead it.
It's a non thing as a non thing that
happens by accident after you've pursued
and struggled and kicked yourself around
the block 400 gazillion times and one
day you look at and you
say, okay, I've done that.
I've done that and people are turning
to you and saying, lead us. You know?
Huh.
On more than one occasion,
I was delighted to have been really put
in my place when I ask questions like,
so how did you find that leadership
journey as a woman on Hollywood?
And she said, are you nuts? That's not
how we go about a journey that matters.
It's not about you.
It's about each of us individually
finding that silent scream and reaching in
and having the humility and the Hubris
to make choices about moving towards that
mission. And if it's ever not
a struggle, then good for you.
But what the people who are feeling,
they're silent, scream, feeding them.
And so being a very powerful combination
of Hubris and humility. I think about,
I met Steve Jobs in high school.
I was a freshman, he was a senior.
There was a summer at homestead high
school where we met each other in a place,
well, I shouldn't even tell you, but I
was in the principal's office with him
and I will tell you why we were there so
long or had such an opportunity to bond.
But I will tell you that
it was interesting to,
to hear him talk about his dreams and
at that time where I was in my life,
all that was was frightening to me.
To hear his hubris and his sense
of ambition and creativity.
There's no way I was going to chase him.
This is not a story of me spending time
in that garage and becoming a business
building and there was no way I could
possibly surrender at that point to the
seduction of what he already had, which
was clarity about that silent scream.
Later, I would have the privilege of
meeting him as Steve To oh, because I,
at that point in my career,
and by 1999 I was chairman of a company
that invented this little thing. Um,
anyone know what that is? Yeah. An MP.
Three player. Right, exactly. Like what?
I'm very proud of the fact that while
other technology has all turned over in
the last 25 years, nobody would think
that was still be on your device.
But it's on pretty much everybody's
device today. Still the MP three player,
the audio is chairman of that.
The little startup company and it was
giving a speech at Stanford and Steve Jobs
was going through his resurrection and
he came up to the front. He said, mark,
you're an idiot.
This is a geeky piece of crap and we're
going to crush it in about two years.
You want to come work for
me? What a recruiting this
is. This was Steve to Datto.
Don't let that attitude
ever be an excuse to,
I don't know how many leaders tell me,
well Steve behaved that way. I said,
well there's an outlier once we disrupt
for different industries and maybe we
have the privilege of being
that kind of personality.
But even he had started to recognize
that it wasn't about him anymore.
He was going to have to recruit a players
from so many different fields and it
was always about staying hungry and
staying foolish enough that this time he
wasn't going to lose this as company
again. But it's interesting to see,
and I say this with the grace and
love respect cause because I had an
opportunity to work with him over a
three year period, he, he'd come a lot,
a long way as a leader. But when you
think about what was it just last week,
apple became the most valuable company
in the world, broke uh, $1 trillion.
They had already been the most
valuable company in the world,
but it wasn't until 2011 in his passing
that the company went on to become the
most valuable in the world.
And it was interesting
how he is transformation
certainly contributed to the
inertia in that company, but he didn't
turn all of his wounds into wisdom.
This guy did chuck Schwab
being fiercely independent,
having this Hubris,
but then also being set
by back by dyslexia.
When I met him,
he talked about how there was no way
that he could have built a company if it
hadn't been by finding people who
had the strengths that he lacked.
And it turns out at
Stanford Business School,
he ended up being one of the people who
most quickly scaled a business out of
business school because he never thought
he was the smartest guy in the room.
He always chose to recruit a team around
him that could do the things that he
couldn't. He put his life's
work, his silent scream,
turned it into passions,
and then instantly recruited a team to
that dream who else could contribute to
that dream and those sets of passions in
ways that they owned and ways that they
could make a unique contribution
of their own independent impact.
Listen to how chuck talks about this.
This is another piece of archival.
How'd you go about coping when you were,
you went on to college and,
and started your career?
How did it all through college?
I got to call eyes by
the, uh, you know, uh,
by a lot of luck and uh, sometimes
I think even mirrors, uh,
because I flunked English a a
couple of times at Stanford and a,
it was a very debilitating,
depressing thing for me to do that cause
I was thought it was pretty bright and
I didn't realize how incompetent
I was in the skill of writing.
In some respects.
The positive side of this learning issue
thing was probably my early recognition
that I wasn't strong in every,
every component of, uh, of,
you know, reading, writing,
all those kinds of things that I needed
to have other people who could help me
out in different parts of the
business that it was developing.
A lot of people who are brilliant, we'll
say, and who are brilliant entrepreneurs,
think they can do everything and they
don't develop the team that they need to
have in order to accomplish that various
levels that you're going to reach in
your growth curve as a successful company.
And so at every level this Schwab has
moved to. I've been able to, I think,
recognize my strengths and my deficits
and build up around me with great people
in the deficit area.
And I think that probably has been maybe
the one single most important benefit
that I achieved or received from uh,
having this learning issue
early on in my life. Uh,
so it's a little perverse
in some respects,
but at least that's the
way I rationalize it.
Best bosses I ever had spent
12 years working at his side,
really informed the way I decide now.
Whenever I think about what I want
to do next, I always think about who
don't. Just think what think, who.
Think about the community of
people who might share that value,
might be able to contribute to it in
ways that would be profound for them as
well in their own unique characteristics.
This works as well in organizations as
it does with your individual passions.
Always recruit a team to
that dream that you have.
And he did this in a such a
beautiful way and with dyslexia. Now,
here's one of the leaders who was
really changing the way we think about
learning. He's got a wonderful
foundation called all kinds of mines,
finding geniuses everywhere with every
type of learning that's out there.
I suffered a disability early in my life.
An eyesight disability would
read it profoundly difficult
for me to read even up
until middle school.
So whenever I'm introduced as a New
York Times bestselling author, author,
I always kind of go, you're
talking about me, David. Um,
because that was always my struggle.
I could tell stories as well.
But that eyesight issue made it
difficult with motor skills and certain
cognitive processes until I
got through adolescence and I,
and it was one of the things that called
me to the work that I do today in terms
of executive coaching,
because I always felt that everyone
had their own form of genius,
that maybe there are a and B players. But
truthfully, it's more about a alignment,
finding the things that we were profoundly
gifted at and be able to contribute
that with other people around us.
Turning your wounds into wisdom.
Principle number five, that's
important. And I'd love for you to,
to ask yourself this
question if you could today,
the people who have life life's
filled with happiness and joy,
people who have lives that are filled
with meaning take a moment each day or
each week and shine a spotlight on
who and what in their life and work is
working.
And one of the takeaways I'd love for
you to do when you leave here today is to
think of somebody to think I've got Karen
May hear people development at Google
who's encouraged me to do this work and
and encouraged me to go around the world
with Googlers to think about this.
I have,
David is a dear friend now who's
developed these last couple of years.
You'll be getting a note.
I still have every note that Chuck
Schwab and Steve Jobs ever wrote me.
I'll never throw that away.
Just think about the last night that
you wrote to somebody, right? One,
send that email.
It doesn't take that much effort to
thank someone and it makes a profound
difference and cognitively and
emotionally and how it touches you.
Some people call that gratitude,
but that sounds Corny to me.
I'm really talking about who
and what works in your life.
It was really a Richard Branson who's,
who's continued to support this work
for my coauthor Bonita Thompson and my
daughter who's kind of
a half Gugler. Uh, the,
the work that she did at an internship
here at 18 changed her life.
I want to thank you guys at Google for
having such a profound impact on my
daughter because she's now a stem major.
She went from being a
political science major,
which she was planning to go to school
and she's now Berkeley math and she's
pursuing a Haas a degree next.
So thank you for the contribution
you made to her life.
See how good that feels to be able
to say something like that. The,
the principle of having a place that's
safe to tinker came up over and over
again. It all 110 nations, no matter
who we talked to as achievers,
there was always a safe
place for a garage.
And I called this in a garage because
if you think about silicon valley were
filled with garages, which don't
have cars. I don't know about you,
but when I was growing up, I never
visited a garage that had a car in it.
What would you, what would you put a
car? Unless you're inventing a car,
why would you put a car in a garage?
This was a safe place to tinker and create
a new dream or build something or do
that craft project. And you know, if it
wasn't good enough to show the world,
nobody can get to know.
It wasn't good enough to leave the garage.
It didn't leave the garage. And so what's
interesting in organizations and in,
in the businesses that I've helped
build and in the lives that I've helped
support, you need a place to tinker.
Where's your garage? It's amazing.
Just across the bay at Pixar,
I work with Jim Morris over there.
It's amazing to see how they have safe
places to tinker on massively expensive
creative projects like films at Pixar is,
you know, if you read Ed Catmull's book,
I think one of the very best leadership
books around and thinking about creating
a life that matters is to read creativity
inc because he talks about that place
where you brainstorm and
it's completely safe.
This is a brainstorming room and
you never criticize anybody eyes,
anybody's ideas in that brainstorming
room, you plus it up, you add to it.
If you're going to be critical,
you're out of there.
You've got to be able to
build on pylon in a new way.
So where is your community of or your
mastermind for the dream that you want to
follow?
Is there a safe place to do that and have
people come and pile on ideas and then
it, at least at Pixar, they realize
they have to run a business.
So then they take it to
another room to say, okay,
now we're going to deconstruct the
crime here. Set priorities, which are,
that's miserable. I hate
setting priorities. You know,
no entrepreneur wants to decide which
goes in which stays and what's done now
and what's done next.
And then they have a third room
where they operationalize things.
That's the business school that has to
be practiced in order to run a business.
So try to think about a sense of place.
We're all as humans,
the environment does when we do this
at Google in terms of having creative
spaces.
But remember,
if you can have a place that you
designate that's safe to create,
safe to incubate, and safe to
deliver, that's really important.
We've found it coming
up over and over again.
Another principle that we found in,
in this cohort of the high
achievers was that they,
like we talked earlier
about the silent scream.
Anyone here have a secret
fear that they've run across?
We all have different phobias and
fears that we've had to face. Um,
can I give you a stupid one for me?
Uh, and I guess it's pretty safe to,
to tell this crowd about just being,
having a,
a fear of heights and roller
coasters. I still, even to this day,
never been on a rollercoaster and
not have any consequences at least,
and this was hard when I became a daddy,
because I would walk my daughter to the
matter horn at Disney and I hear the
screams of delight and I heard
her screams of the light. She,
she looked like this little one here
and we'd walk closer and closer,
the melting down pat feeling
my hands getting sweaty and,
and by the time we got just up to deliver
her and put her on the ride, I'd say,
Daddy's got to take a call.
Mommy's gonna ride with you.
And that's what we do every time.
You know,
it was just like she saw it through that.
She shot through that very quickly.
Well,
one of the things that I'm embarrassed
to say that I didn't really discover it
until this year and understanding in this
data that I've been collecting for 20
years, and it was around this idea that
often people who are high achievers,
they may or may not face a fear down,
but they almost never think about it
as being a potential source of joy.
If we could prepare for it,
what if there was some way that we could
somehow prepare for this difficulty in
our life in a way that there just might
be some shred of joy that comes from it.
That might to be an unlocked for me and
there ended up being one for me in this
particular case. I decided that yes.
Okay. I was going to be ambitious here.
I was going to toughen up.
I was going to face,
my fear is going to take a
group of, of my clients, uh,
it was the founder of Pinterest,
the CEO of of HP and the staff.
We rented a zero g plane and we went up
in the so called vomit comments and what
they do is they rent 10 miles by 100
miles of the stratosphere and they do 15
parabolas and you know down you're doing
three g's and up. You're doing well,
zero g and I, it was some macho
thing in me that said, oh,
I just have to do this, you know, for,
forget the roller coasters
are the skydiving. I'm going
to prepare for this now.
I'm 20 years older than
everybody who's on the plane.
So I trained rigorously for this.
I started studying.
Why is it that you get nauseous, mark?
Why do you get Vertigo? It's interesting.
I'd never leaned into my fear.
I'd never studied how was,
what do we know about people who have
fear of heights? Why do I have this fear?
How could I address this fear?
I guess I could go to therapy,
but then that was be just a cycle.
I wasn't really coaching myself.
I wasn't a very good student.
So I s I deconstructed this fear.
Now I'm not saying I conquered it.
I don't think that's true.
I think what you do is
you actually manage it,
but I never thought
that I might harvest it.
So I ended up going up in the
vomit comet because you know,
and I was thinking this all along, it was
thinking about the roller coaster ride.
I'm not going to be like
Ryan was in that movie,
but I was going to try to
find a way to go into zero g.
Well that was fun.
I would do that every day of the week.
Something that apps that was,
that was doing something.
I can't imagine anything more frightening
than to deal with looking out into the
stratosphere and looking from dark
to light and plunging like that.
I stayed on the course.
I,
I stayed very disciplined
about what they asked me to do,
but I never expected to enjoy it.
Okay.
What fears do we have in our life that
are holding us back that there might be
just the shred of an unlock that we are
worthy of leaning into and learning more
about?
That's something I'd never thought I
would explore for myself before and I,
I would see it.
I observed it and I've been hearing
people tell me this for 20 years and never
internalized it until this year
or found a way to exercise it.
You learn throughout life.
I'm hitting my 60th birthday here and
finding a new joy that I missed that last
60 years.
Now I'm feeling greedy.
What else have I missed about what makes
life special and what makes life so
rich and creative?
And this is what is unique about this
cohort of people that I've found who
continued to reevaluate how to create a
life that matters and look at success.
So let's deconstruct that one level
further here. In the final piece,
I want to ask you folks,
if a loved one came to you not knowing
anything about what you do for a living
but their loved ones, it could be
a child or a parent and asked you,
what's your definition of success?
What would, what would you tell them?
Just at the highest level, what would be
your definition of success? Anyone here?
There's no right answer anyway. David,
what would be your definition of success?
I Love, love me and are better
human beings because of that.
Is that a lovely definition of success?
Give him a round of applause.
That's beautiful.
That the community that I care about is
better off because we're together and
that you contributed to that community.
Anyone else?
What would be another
definition of success? Yes.
Fulfillment
and being able to do some of those
passions that maybe we talked about.
Maybe if you were a silent screams,
give him a round of applause.
That's a great definition that you could
find another part of your life that you
yes.
Happiness.
What a concept that to come with success
and that we'd be dividends of both of
these others. That's a great to give
her a round of applause. Success.
Any other definitions of success?
Okay.
Anything else that comes
to mind? She dropped. She,
she was doing her hair back there.
So you won the bid.
What would be your definition?
Um, well it's not my definition,
but a definition associated with
pain.
Yes, exactly. So this is an
interesting point that will make,
so if you looked up the definition
of success in the dictionary,
which actually didn't occur to me to
do 20 years ago when we started the
research, but our warden
team said like, if you could,
we're going to publish this book
with Prentice Hall. You know,
we got to do the research,
look in the dictionary.
That was the definition in the dictionary.
But that's it.
The definition that we heard from people
who had high impact in their lives and
had developed lives that truly matter
for them and others didn't have wealth,
fame or goals actually on the list.
So what we teach our kids
or feel conflicted about,
one of the reasons the silent screen is
so profound is because we have a double
standard on how we define success
in every language. By the way,
if you can find another one,
I'll send you a nice bonus.
If you can find a way that deaf,
the definition of success is
to find anywhere else. It's,
it's a punishing evil
definition of success, frankly,
because it's not how successful people
who've had lives that matter long periods
of time define success. In
fact, the definition of success,
I shouldn't be surprised.
And I hear this, a Google,
wherever I go in the world and
I'm now asking people live in,
in meetings like this, 10 15,000 people,
they define success, the success,
the same way that you did in this room.
And it ends up being characterized
this way. And the and,
and the thing I want to say about
this is also for you to notice.
You should never assume that you know
somebody's definition of success.
There's more than one definition.
I'm not sure that your definition of
success might have been the same even five
years ago. The check in to find out what
a person's definition of success is.
You might be profoundly
touched by how they frame it.
If knowing that about David or knowing
that about how you sense this connection
with your passions makes a difference
in your relationship with that person.
How they define that success.
There's not just waited one to do it.
What we found was that there's three
categories of the definition of success.
All three of these were present in
everyone who'd had impact for 20 years or
more.
They had a sense of a purpose or a cause,
something that they were associated
with that was greater than themselves,
but that they believed in,
that they cared about.
They had a sense of
passions and connection.
They had a sense of the who they wanted
to be with through their purpose,
but also through their
hobbyists and through their
passions and through the work
that they wanted to do.
And then they also had a a way of
actually wanting to deliver on the goods.
I mean it's one thing
to be purpose driven,
but it's hard to really earn the right
to do that unless you can deliver on some
of your promises that if this what we'd
call the genius of the end rather than
material, any of the your that that
when you're feeling out of balance,
it's not just because you can't do
enough of the one thing that you love.
It's because we're often not doing things
that we can see connected to something
bigger than us or a
community bigger than us.
And that also feeds our passions.
The passions are about things
that we would do on our own.
They're not about winning.
There are about doing something we
believe in that we want to refine this.
Something that we want to be a part of
performance has to do with our ability to
deliver on those things.
And,
and what I'd love to do right now is just
serve you a set of definitions around
passion.
So you can mind this a little deeper.
So what we found is that there are
really six dimensions of passion.
And the reason I have my Angela and Warren
Buffet up here is because when I went
to visit Maya Angelo, she talked about
how most of us don't live our lives,
feelings,
all three of these,
that it's easy to maybe focus on one
but not the other two. That wouldn't,
we're feeling out of balance. It's
because we haven't decided, wait, okay,
so how is this connected to something
bigger than me or longer term?
Some people might even call
this a legacy and you know,
could this could be a community,
it could, it doesn't have to.
It could be a company,
it could be a customer,
just something bigger than ourselves.
Passions are for you.
Performance is how we deliver an express.
All of those.
So let's go through purpose,
passion, and performance.
But one thing about Warren Buffet,
Warren Buffet won't accept a job inquiry
from an individual unless they qualify
for all three of these.
He says,
a lot of people will have a sense of
how they've served to a business or a
purpose in the past.
They'll express maybe how they've
delivered in terms of performance,
but when it comes to passion,
most people put that off and don't
integrate that in with their work.
That that passion is not something you
should put off to another time and needs
to be a part of your everyday work.
He said that that passion to put off
your passions is a little bit like saving
up sex for old age.
It's a really bad idea.
We should be living full out right now.
And I said,
good for you wore and I want to
be that way. When I made a right,
the oracle of Omaha says that we should
be living full out and so should the Po,
the Po. So there's the Poe, the
poet, and she expresses her life.
So let's look quickly at passion.
Passion. We found this portfolio.
Passions. We talked about, you can,
you can look at this set of passions
in the sense that one of the ways to
evaluate whether you're doing something
you're passionate about is that you will
lose sense of time.
Mikael, Chez Mal, Holly,
the social scientist would call
experts in their field where they,
the were artists are chemists and say,
how long have you been working on
the project? Don't look at a watch.
They could never say your
unconscious competence.
You will lose that when you're in
the flow, ever been in the flow.
You're doing something else and it
starts to contribute to answering the
question. As soon as you let go of the
problem you're running, you're reading,
you're doing your favorite knitting,
then it starts to flow for you.
So think when you watch the flow,
that's usually an indication of passion.
We tend to have a bias when it comes
to defining failure. Generally,
when you're doing something you're
passionate about, it's not a failure.
It's a learning.
We redefine it.
I used to run and play
music in high school.
I don't run anymore because I wasn't
that good at it. So I failed at that,
but I'm still playing the horn even
though I wasn't that good at it.
But I'm learning, I'm getting
better and better. Um, I,
I'm still trying to be creative that way.
We tend to be proactive and do the
things we're passionate about first.
We like to think we're objective,
but we have decision by us.
The things that get at the top of the
list are generally the ones that we feel
the most passionate about.
I'm thinking over this because
I'm not a behavioral psychologist.
I really wanted to look at
how the behavioral data,
what we did a forced ranking and we
asked people in this conjoint analysis to
determine what they really cared about
this is these were the dimensions of
passion. That passion is something
you'd secretly do for free.
Now I know we're at Google is a business,
but we're all hopefully driven
not just by the clock, right?
We are driven with doing something some
aspect of the day. I mean life is short,
but some days are very long,
right?
Not Everything we do is something
we love and it's not what I'm really
proselytizing hear.
What I'm saying is that there needs to
be some aspect of the work we do that
feeds us even with out
traditional compensation.
You bore people when you're passionate,
so you go to a party and you know
somebody asks me about my daughter,
please don't make this mistake.
I will not shut up.
You'll be looking at me saying,
I'm so happy for you, mark,
and they're looking at their watch.
They feel the aging process.
They don't know how to get
out of the conversation.
Mark is still geeking over it.
You're not politically correct or socially
conscious entirely when you're in a
state of passion, when you're, when
you're living your passion. Now,
this is an important way to deconstruct
relationships because it's good to know
what's flipping.
Somebody switched so that you can either
feed that for them or help align them
with that on a project or help associate
with them. If you share that passion,
this is another dimension of it.
You definitely bore people when you're
passionate about something and it's also
something that you would hope that in
history that you'd like to be remembered
for. It usually is the
kind of thing that I, Gosh,
I'd love to say that the passions
that I've been living in,
the purpose I'm feeling could somehow be
remembered that somehow would be a part
of my legacy that could somehow
maybe make a difference. Um,
and it would be make a life worth living.
I do some that do spend some
considerable time up at Nike.
And what's the slogan at
Nike that's most famous,
which you'll have to have a slogan
like that. Everybody in any language,
it always comes back, just do it in
English. Why is that so compelling?
Kind of cuts through the clutter and the
bullshit of our lives and the pressure
and the denial that comes from other
people about what we really want to do.
We just want to do it,
but we don't want to just do anything.
I want to do something that matters.
I love the current positioning
that they have right now.
They talk about trying to
find your inner athlete,
whether you are an athlete or not,
and to play, to be remembered.
I think what we'd all to feel is
that somehow the impact and the,
and the creativity and the
meaning that we found in our life
would mean that we had played in to be
remembered that we were writing our own
future.
That that would be perhaps the most
profound way to think about our lives. Um,
I'd like it all just
stand up for a moment.
I asked you the definition of success
and I just want to make a closing
request of you all and then
we'll do some Q. And. A.
I asked you a moment ago
your definition of success
and you were processing this and
hoping I wasn't going to call on you.
And as you were doing that,
I'd like to now invite you to think about
the fact that the success that you've
achieved is not entirely yours.
It's also because there's
a contribution from others,
that there's other people in your life
and your work that have helped make you
successful. Isn't that right?
It's not just about you.
So could you try to picture
in your mind for a moment,
someone in your life or work who's
somehow contributing to the success that
you've enjoyed in your life? Can you,
can you get that picture in your mind?
If that person was trying somehow to
get through Google security and is now
being arrested at the front door,
do you think you could make a noise so
loud to alert them all that they should
let him,
he or she in,
do you think you could make a noise so
loud in this room that you could indicate
how much you love this person? One, two,
three. I'm then on the count of three,
you're going to give me a noise so loud
that you're going to have them released
from security. One, two,
three go. Okay, very nice.
Please sit down. That's great. That's
great. They're letting them through now.
Could you check on that?
Yeah.
I wish I'd had somebody there at this
morning when I was trying to get in. Um,
the reason I did that is because there's
so few times in our life and work that
we really show that level of gratitude
to the people that mean the most to us.
Would you promise me one thing that when
you leave here today that you could let
those few people who qualified for you
at that mental list of success know that
you gave them a shout out today? As
corny as that may be, that that'll,
that'll make your day better.
That'll make you feel profoundly better.
And it's what the most creative high
impact people do. Thank you so much.
I'd love to take questions.
Thank you.
Hi Mark. Thanks. Sure. Yeah.
There's the three p's and I feel like
certain ones come easier to me than others
and damn straight.
Yeah.
So like getting stuff done or
performance. Yeah, sure. Yeah.
Um, does the passion and
then there's the purpose.
A purpose one. Yeah. I
can serve through it.
That's not natural.
How does it get to come to you?
Is it really a thought process
or it's like really centering.
It comes from the heart. The, have you
heard of people struggling with that?
Yes,
absolutely.
And I think we have reaffirm kind of
what we believe in and reevaluate that
probably at many different points
in our life and in our career.
But what we found is that
the process that, that,
that many people go through is to try to,
to,
to get a sense of what their purpose
might be by looking at their career over
time and seeing what are the proudest
moments that you have in your personal
life. What were the proudest
moments that you have?
What were the ones that give you
the most energy on reflection?
Lay it out in a timeline.
Um,
and one of the ways that you can observe
that list is to start to deconstruct
would be the three or five reasons in
terms of purpose of that work that you
were doing. Frame it that way
that it gave you that response.
Let's start with what
gives you a sense of pride.
Now I'm grossly oversimplifying a much
deeper process that we can talk about,
but the idea is to say that are those
areas of your life that you're the
proudest about kind of feeding
a sense of purpose in any way.
They may also be feeding a sense of
passion and some of the things that you'd
just like to do for your own sake.
And it helps separate it from a moment
from achievement because usually when you
answer those questions
of proud of most moments,
you've probably already tick
the box for performance.
We're especially in Western society,
very much trained towards outcomes and
achievement and we are programmed for
that.
That's part of the silent scream.
If there's something that we love
that's not achievement oriented,
that's probably in the silent scream
category. It's one of those hard,
hard things to resurrect into your
active portfolio passions that you have.
It's very easy to define success.
Looking back, so like, uh,
I don't know,
like if laddie started out with the
mission of organizing the world's
information, I was like a book.
It started out with you know,
organizing with lake kind of run the world
vision is history of the past, right?
Yeah, so looking forward like how
do you define your mission or lake?
How do you know what you
are passionate about?
Because honestly I don't know what
I'm passionate about at this point.
You know it's because of a lot of inertia
that we often lose track of what we
feel that are most most passionate about.
Which is why I would love to,
I'll I can send to you and you'll also
find in the book or if he didn't get a
copy of the book we can send that to you.
I'd be happy to send that free the
criteria around passion because you can
explore some of those areas that speak
to use those areas that you find that you
are talking about a little
bit too long with a loved one.
The the category of areas where you find
yourself spending time when you're not
working. Is there something you're
naturally being gravitated to? What?
What are those areas that you are not
putting a spotlight on now because they're
not achievement oriented
or outcome oriented.
Is there anything that you particularly
look forward to in the work that you're
doing right now?
What aspect of it do you hate?
What aspect do you love about that?
I often go through a process where it's
more interesting to look at what you
hate and see why you hate it and
you think that's a really dumb idea.
Why would we look at the things that we
consider a failure and hate the most?
Because what's shocking is if you
share that with three other people,
they may not agree you as being,
that's the worst thing
that ever happened to them.
What's so shocking in the work that I do
among high achievers is that I'll just
assume that the things that people love
or this and the things that they hate
her, that, and I'm wrong every
single time that a person might say,
gosh, well what I hate about
this is that, that, uh,
nobody knows that I did the work and I'm
not getting recognition. And, and uh,
so I don't feel significant here
unless I have a speaking part.
And the next person over who's
a high achiever will say,
what I hate most about this is I have to
get up every time and speak about this.
I can't stand being in front of a crowd.
So to deconstruct what it is
that's that you hate so much,
and I call this kind of
ballast the things that are,
if you were to look at the
high points in your life,
the proudest moments and the
worst moments in your life,
and just spend an extra moment looking
at why you hate the things you hate.
There's probably, uh, if
you flip that into energy,
if you flip that into why
it's holding you down,
you'll get the insight into something
that could be really miraculous in your
life. So my, my wife, who is my
coauthor on all of this work,
uh, her brother died when he
was 21, he was already taking,
he was already bicycling
over to NASA savant a genius.
And you might ask three people, obviously
the loss of a brother when you're 18,
and he's 21 particularly would be
so profoundly impacting your life.
And you'll almost find as many reasons
in this room why that's a bad thing as
there are people in this room.
But for her,
the greatest loss was the lack of
contribution that he would have.
The rural lost a genius.
That's probably not the first thing.
The next three people would say.
So what did that do to inform what she
cherishes and believes that I'm going to
spend my life?
I realized that's what I care about.
I'm projecting it on all the
other important people in my life.
So she spends her life trying to create
a life that matters for others. For me,
I was held back because of a developmental
disability. I never know a suit,
a person's intelligence or capacity until
we actually worked together to try to
unlock what that is because everybody
has a certain form of genius and the most
key part of innovation is to try
to unlock that particular genius.
I have endless patients for
that because if I didn't,
I wouldn't believe in myself. It's a, it's
a personal projection of that passion.
Yeah.
Thank you for this affair.
An inspirational talk. Um,
so the common definition of success
is a bit money, fortune and fame,
power and all that.
And then I can tell if I'm going to
talk like you and your friends probably
enjoyed a lot of that. My meanwhile,
we're all losers. We're just, yeah.
By meanwhile,
do you agree that I'm in [inaudible]
people just don't have those majority by
just common people. Yes. You know,
my sound was it goes to homestead
high and I tried to east by him, Hey,
look at this Steve Job,
Great Java. He said, dad,
he was just an exception.
I'm a normal kid. Yes,
that makes sense. So it's a fair,
it's a fair point, right? Yeah.
Do you think not fall common people he
saw seen point of the fan debt sacked
Sachi and can pan farm from just
doing normal things just be 10,
10. We see. Why don't we,
we got absolutely just for
a paying job at Google.
That's what happened. Yeah. Yeah.
You're definitely a very
normal underprivileged Gugler
because
do you know they're just,
that sets the bar a certain place that
is maybe a little also privileged. Um,
the point of all this,
it really is that it's for each and every
one of us to find their, our purpose,
our passion and performance.
The only reason I used to famous
examples is because you know them.
And because I was shocked
at how inadequate each and
every one of them were to
the task that they were faced with.
And yes,
maybe they're the long
tail or the Unicorn,
but each and every one of us or a unicorn
that that that really we should be
looking at.
The standard that we're
setting the standard that
you're setting at Google from
your son is that he lived
a life that matters to him.
Nobody else can make that decision
for him. And that's the silent scream.
So your job is to say not to talk about
Steve Jobs because he's actually a
terrible role model,
is to talk about what's so special about
him that he lays up at night thinking
about that. He's afraid to talk to
you about that you could empower.
So he could be lighting
up the sky with that work.
It may not be politically correct.
He may not become a doctor or a lawyer,
but he might end up being the best
creator. You might be the best inventor.
What could you feed?
Jane Goodall would lose the daughter
at four eight she was four years old.
She'd wander off and,
and she'd looked for hours for a daughter
and daughter would be found there.
She was looking at the lizards and
she was looking at the bugs. Well,
that wasn't a politically
correct profession in a
family that had all doctors
and lawyers and she became jade
Goodall. So there's a, there's a,
there's a shred of a place of,
of joy and contribution and,
and that's what we as parents
are so challenged to. Yes.
Um, there was a quote earlier
is something about, um,
winners and losers and winners
lose more than losers. Yeah.
I was just wondering how would you justify
your losers? It's, it's not a fair,
I'm glad you pointed it out because I'd
be supremely disappointed if I didn't
get called on that. So thank you.
Give her a big round of applause.
So if there's any great exception,
I think
by the way this is presented,
you'd never talk about winners and losers.
The reason I did that though
is for a very specific reason,
and that is that if
you talk to people who,
if you didn't know that they had had
some celebrity or, or additional success,
you'd find that they spent more airtime
talking on their failures than their
successes.
That they were learning from iterating
towards an outcome that they will,
to seeking. The point I was really
trying to make there is that we,
we fail more often than we succeed if
we're really trying hard at something we
care about and that's okay.
In fact,
that's the only way to
fail forward to success.
Usually 10 times more losses than
wins for people who were trying to do
something meaningful.
Yeah.
If you feel like you don't
have a silent scream,
is it better to a hope
it comes organically, uh,
be cultivate one that
you want to have or see.
Just kind of give up on
the idea that you matter.
It sounds like a standard
Google bubble test.
Isn't there a d all of the
above or none of the above?
Um, the, this, it doesn't have
to be so much a silent scream.
I mean the good news might
be do you enjoy your work
moderately, moderately. I
enjoy everything moderately.
So like there's not like a peak or a low.
Okay. So it's a matter of starting to
notice whether there's peaks or Lowe's.
It's starting to notice the things that
really irritate you the most because
there might be the germ of something
you really care about there.
So I have good friends who you know,
are just offended if they see bad code.
Um, I see. I have friends who are
offended if they see a bad ad written.
These are things are insights into maybe
she should be spending some more time
doing copywriting on ads.
And that's not something you've ever
been offered in your life most likely.
It's so amazing to me being a late parent
and having my daughter go to a grade
school like Berkeley. But it's
interesting asking the kids don't,
what do you want to do and why do you
keep changing your mind? It's because dad,
we never got asked a choice.
We were never offered an opportunity
to test new ideas out. Right.
That's not what you're really allowed
to do. Pass the AP test, right?
Get the performance done. So things
do end up getting kind of mediocre.
Like I like everything kind of moderately
well cause I did get A's in those
classes. But you really haven't
been offered this opportunity.
Now to step back for a moment and look
at the things that are your highs and
your lows,
you'll start to see some of them.
And if you do some more
reading about the passion test,
you're going to find that some of those
areas do activate you more than others.
Some are,
you're better at some of those.
Speak to you more and that that might
be a way to start to find a way to lean
into those, those ideas. All
right. Thank you everybody.
Appreciate it. Thank you. Thank you.